My name is Rutger Bregman.
I'm a historian,
and in my humble opinion
bin men and women
should be paid more than bankers.
So a good way
to illustrate this point
is to look at a couple of strikes
that happened throughout history.
So for example in New York, 1968,
there was a big strike of bin men.
They were just angry that their wages
were not going up anymore
so they said, 'You know what,
we're gonna go on strike
and then you'll see just
how important we are.'
And indeed, six days later,
the state of emergency
had to be declared.
New York really couldn't handle it.
Turns out you can't
do without bin men.
Two years later there was another
strike, in this case of bankers.
It's the only strike that
I know of throughout history
where the bankers
actually went on strike.
And all the experts at that point,
all the economists,
they all predicted disaster.
This was supposed to be like
a heart attack for the economy.
But then the strike started.
And nothing much happened really.
It actually lasted
for six months in the end.
the economy just kept growing,
businesses kept operating.
There are nowadays
many people in professions
in say Wall Street or Silicon Valley
that are often described
as the visionaries and the whizkids
who come up with
all these wonderful products.
There was someone at Facebook
who worked there for years
and said, "the best minds
of my generation
are thinking about how
to make people click ads."
That's one of the tragedies
of our time
is that we're wasting so much talent.
There are so many
smart people right now
in jobs that don't
contribute anything.
And it's not necessary.
It's not inevitable.
We need to rethink who the real
wealth creators actually are
in our society.
So there's some
fascinating research actually,
new research from
two Dutch economists.
Max van Lent and Robert Dur who
looked at this whole phenomenon
of what they call...
They asked people the question...
Turns out that in modern economies,
developed economies,
25% of the workforce says...
Now who are these people,
is an interesting question.
Turns out that actually, they have
wonderful LinkedIn profiles.
They have wonderful,
excellent salaries,
they're often at the
top of the pyramid.
They're bankers,
corporate lawyers, consultants.
Basically, you know, a lot of people
sitting in offices all day,
sending emails
to people they don’t like,
writing reports
no-one's ever going to read
but still making a lot of money.
So that's quite fascinating right.
That the rest of the population
is supporting this whole
class of people
who don't really contribute anything.
Right? What we're doing is
we're spending billions of pounds
to educate our best and brightest
and they go to Oxford and Cambridge
and then they go on and they do jobs
that they absolutely don't like.
I mean, it's not me saying,
it's people themselves saying it,
where they don't
really contribute anything.
What's going on here?
Who are the real wealth creators?
And the reality here is, I think,
is that we're living in an
inverse welfare state.
Where most wealth is
actually created at the bottom
by people who are doing
the real work.
The teachers, the nurses,
the garbage collectors, you know.
This state of affairs, it's not
inevitable, we can change it
and I would like to live in a society
where we actually pay people
according to their contribution.
Where we have a real meritocracy.
And in such a society
I believe in the long run
bin men and women will be paid
more than bankers.
Thanks for watching.
Don’t forget to subscribe! :)